thank you
[Music]
hey guys what's going on it's another
day
of whatever it is
crazy ass it's Tuesday you crazy ass
Stephen King movies
there's a lot of shitty Stephen King
movies all right this is actually a good
one I actually kind of enjoyed this yeah
I did as well we had a good cast
the dude that plays the lead role is the
same guy that played the uh the young
executive from ocp on RoboCop that had
RoboCop Miguel Ferrer yeah yeah what's
is that his name ago what Ferrer Ferrer
okay yeah he was also great he's also
good in the uh the made for TV stand
it's Stephen King Stand he's in that
so um
he carries this movie and uh does a
great job it's a low budget flick
but it's a good story
and my only gripe about it is that
you can stream it free off of YouTube
because somebody uploaded because
somebody you can't find it I can't find
it's like legally and it's which is
stupid and it did this this movie badly
needs to be remastered
it's in television aspect ratio
instead of theatrical and this is
definitely made for maybe it's made for
VHS I don't know no I found out well I
found out what happened with it because
I was wondering that too I was like why
is this in TV I said I know it wasn't
made for TV because it's like every
other word is [ __ ] and there's like a
lot of Gore in it yeah so I was like
obviously I didn't make this for TV
initially this was supposed to get a
theatrical release and it did get a
theatrical release in Italy okay
um it was supposed to get one in the U.S
but then I think it was Paramount or I
can't remember like what production
company it was but then they were like
uh they're like well we can release it
but it's gonna be like a year ahead
because their schedule was too crowded
and because the movie was independently
financed uh the producers of the movie
were kind of like well we can't make the
the you know the finance people like
wait that long like to release the movie
so what they did was they released it to
HBO and then later gave it a theatrical
release like a limited theatrical
release but it didn't do all that well
and I kind I feel like this disappeared
unfortunately because out of all the
Stephen King adaptations that have been
made this is actually like a pretty good
one and you don't really hear a lot of
people talking about it so theoretically
there is a theatrical version with the
original aspect ratio that they could
probably be imagining because this was
an intended as for a theatrical release
and it did get one it needs a remaster
it's got practical effects but they look
good but they look knb like you know
it's nicotero in them yeah it's got good
practical effects
um
uh but they look very muddy they're in
very low resolution and the aspect ratio
is [ __ ] wrong it uh but it doesn't
it doesn't really affect the the uh the
movie when you're watching it for free
you know what I mean if I can but yeah
it didn't really bother me but I
wouldn't mind having a Blu-ray Special
Edition release of this there you might
be able to find something like that
maybe Arrow or blue underground or
somebody will get around to it like I
don't know what the rights issues is but
you could literally can't yeah stream
this legally anywhere I couldn't find it
anywhere yeah so like somebody uploaded
it I'm assuming illegally on YouTube so
we watched it on there and it's not
great well it's like standard definition
but you know it's better than not being
able to see it at all yeah it's the
start is a little muddy so it's it when
the movie starts it seems to be a little
bit slow but it builds up this is a
vampire flick yeah
and really this vampire flick
could can hold its own uh especially a
vampire flick of the 90s there were a
lot of bad vampire movies of the 90s
this is actually pretty good
um
I wouldn't I'd put it I wouldn't put it
I wouldn't say it's better than Salem's
Lot
well that's I mean Salem's Lot was
really really good yeah it stands out
really good that made for TV Sam's life
you could get it if I can if you get a
good copy of it uh it's fun to watch the
tone is a little bit different okay in
this one the tone of this one is more
kind of like made for TV stand
uh it kind of felt like that
uh but the quality was good and um I
liked it I liked it had a lot of good
ideas in it
very Stephen King I liked I think what I
liked about this
um you know the movie came out in 1997.
I think this short story Stephen King
originally wrote it in the late 80s like
1988 or something like that and then
like later on it was in nightmares and
Dreamscapes I remember reading the story
but I don't think I ever saw this movie
and if I did it was a long time ago I
like how they weren't afraid to go like
really really mean-spirited with this
and I really really like that Miguel
Ferrer like playing the main character
um whose name is Richard Dees he just
was just an unashamed [ __ ] I liked
him though but he was still really
compelling like you still wanted to even
though he was just like a horrible
horrible person but he was just so good
I think that's like a testament to the
actor because like he just made you want
to watch him even though he was just
like a complete [ __ ] well you know the
the that other character that he played
from RoboCop was kind of like that he
was kind of a dick but you rooted for
him you liked him right he plays a lot
he's very good at like real good at that
unfortunately Miguel Ferreira passed
away a few years ago oh I didn't know
that 2017 yeah he wouldn't have been
very old no he wasn't I think he was
only in his early 60s maybe I don't know
cancer or something I don't know I don't
know what he died of but yeah he died
like uh younger than you would expect
yeah which is a real shame because he
always looked older than he actually was
he looked a little bit older than what
he was in Robocop he he you could tell
he's one of the younger Executives but I
think he's younger than he seems
probably yeah yeah it might be a little
I think he might have only been late 20s
he's always such a great character actor
though but like I said he's really
excels in this particular niche of
playing just complete unrepentant
[ __ ] but that are still kind of
likable like it's still like you still
want to watch him yeah and he just like
carries this whole [ __ ] movie so much
even though he's literally he's like a
horrible horrible person like I don't
think he has a single retainment quality
but he's still like really really
entertaining I mean the whole point of
the movie is they're drawing a parallel
between him being like uh you know
because he works for a tabloid being
like a blood sucker taking advantage of
you know people and like a literal blood
sucker you know what I mean so they hit
that a little bit hard I mean there was
one kind of uh really really funny line
where his editor is like talking about
the serial killer who's a vampire and
he's like God I hope he kills more
people and it's just like that just made
me like laugh out loud yeah the magazine
they work for is like sub National
Enquirer it's like the star
yeah because because even like National
Enquirer and stuff like I mean I don't
know I haven't read it in a long time
but they wouldn't print like most of the
stuff that yeah because in this movie
they kind of show Richard D's going
around like taking pictures of like
mangled bodies like car accidents and
[ __ ] like I don't even think even the
star did it and I don't even think this
started that it's like the closest they
ever got that I saw was you know they'd
take pictures of like oh Elvis in his
coffin or something like that but as far
as I know I mean you guys I don't know
I'm not an expert but as far as I know
they would have would have balked it
like yeah nothing in America was like
that and I was a kid out in California
growing up in LA area out in Carson
um at the they'd have little news stands
outside the dollar stores with the
Mexican
um newspapers that were like tabloids
and they would have [ __ ] yeah I've
seen them in yeah I've seen them in
other countries in other countries yeah
but I don't think I've ever seen it in
the U I Like It in America you've been
looking through there tripping out oh
man look his head's cut off it would
freak us out when we were kids yeah yeah
but yeah so yeah the so this movie kind
of like posits oh and you know what fun
fact remember how you were saying before
like about all the Stephen King Stories
being like interrelated yeah uh thank
you Trey great movies still kicking butt
guys thank you very much that's very
nice of you yeah
um this character Richard Dees the
journalist first turned up in Stephen
King's novel The Dead Zone he was in one
scene where he goes to Johnny Smith and
like wants to interview him about his
psychic powers and [ __ ] and Johnny Smith
tells him to [ __ ] off and so I guess
Stephen King kind of liked that
character so much that that character
was kind of like in the back of his mind
so he decided to write a short story
that was just based around that
particular character yeah
Stephen King he invented the extended
Universe man this MCU [ __ ] man They're
copying King King [ __ ] came up with
that [ __ ] first
and um there's a good uh fan video on
YouTube of somebody who has read all of
his books and interconnected them all
there's a huge flow chart of what I said
what
and he proves that he shows you where
it's mentioned and this and that and out
of them all there's like only one
that doesn't seem to reference any of
the other ones but it doesn't it doesn't
exclude them it's just that there isn't
any other references right
um it's the same universe anything that
Stephen King writes is happening pretty
much in the same universe and if it's
not in the same universe it's in a
parallel Dimension right but it's still
in this universe like Gunslinger stuff
it's parallel universe but it talks
about this universe too
and I think even the Peter Straub King
Talisman is in the same universe yeah
even though it's happening in another
Dimensions some of it even so even Peter
Straub I think is in the Stephen King
Universe basically his writings yeah I
guess if in that book yeah like I said
they did too they did the Talisman and
then they did a sequel I think it was
called the black house yeah I didn't see
it man I didn't read it I'd probably
like it you probably would yeah you
should probably get around that although
to be honest if I was going to do that
I'd have to read the Talisman again
because it was so long ago Talisman was
awesome that'd make an awesome made for
TV series that make it awesome did the
Talisman have they
I mean they've adapted everything else
yeah it was a [ __ ] horror Road Trip
movie basically two kids one of them's a
[ __ ] werewolf in another dimension in
this Dimension he's not a werewolf but
in the dimension he comes from he is I
am also a werewolf in another yeah
they're trying to walk walk across the
country and they're making leaps into
into another dimension as they're going
to try to find his Talisman it's a good
story
yeah I should probably I kind of feel
like that's another one that I wanted to
like reread because when I read it
before I'm like I'm not as super into
like fantasy as much as I like just like
straight up horror [ __ ] so I kind of
feel like because that was more fantasy
based I didn't get quite as into it I
loved it as a kid yeah because you like
a lot more fantasy and sci-fi stuff I'm
more like yeah as long as it has some
kind of [ __ ] horror type [ __ ] in it
but I like the sci-fi fantasy I mean it
was good
in this universe it's the same but
whenever they would jump into the
parallel Dimension and they had to drink
a potion to do it but that turned out
that it wasn't a potion they could do it
with their minds they just you needed
that as a crutch and you could leap into
the other dimension and whatever was
here there was another version of it on
the other side and it was like a dark
evil version of it
so see I think well that's I think where
stranger things got the idea for uh the
upside down which is kind of like the
same thing it's like a flip side of
there and it's like darker yeah I mean
because stranger things is very very
influenced yeah like Stephen King like
there was a a boarding school for kids
in this universe on the other Universe
it was a damn open pit mine where they
had all these kids enslaved like demonic
kids enslaved and they were going down
and they were mining some kind of
[ __ ] metal or something to make
weapons with and it was like a real
hellish there was demons and [ __ ] it was
basically the mouth to hell or one of
them so there was always something
different in the other Universe yeah
like I said that's where like I said if
you watch stranger things there's a
thing like a yeah a flip side Dimension
that's called the upside down and it's
kind of like a similar type of thing
well I guess in the upside down in in
the talisman
it's the spiritual truth behind what it
is a lot of the times like the dark side
of it like if it's a bad place here it's
even worse somewhere else yeah that's
similar yeah it's like it's similar yeah
Danny Rowling said did they ever explain
the deal with the dirt under Dwight's
plane I thought well because when when
um Richard gets into the plane like into
the vampire's plane and there's like a
pile of dirt that's all maggoty and [ __ ]
I thought it was like a call back to you
know vampires have to sleep in their
native earth type deal yeah and I
thought that just some of it had leaked
out like underneath the bottom that's
what I thought you're talking about
Dracula's uh uh casket on the ship it's
what they're referring to yeah he had to
take his own he had to take the uh the
soil in which he was born with yeah you
got to sleep in the dirt it seems like a
giant pain in the ass so he probably had
some either dirt in the plane or the
casket
from the cat the dirt that was inside
the casket that he unloaded from the
plane some of it fell out some stuff
like that because there was dirt in the
plane there was right because I slept in
a plane that's what I thought like he
just like slept in the place slept in
the plane in a pile of dirt yeah because
there wasn't I didn't even see a casket
in there I think it was just like a pile
of dirt like with maggots and stuff yeah
so I guess he just slept in the back of
the plane but yeah so if you haven't
seen this it's actually the short story
um I think is only 40 pages long so
obviously that's not really long enough
like for a feature-length movie so they
had to add some [ __ ]
so the character uh you know kind of
like the rookie reporter lady they added
that character to just have somebody for
Richard D's to like um you know kind of
play off of because she was kind of like
the young naive rookie reporter and she
was like real ambitious and she wanted
this story and then you know what I mean
so and then like her
also the end is different because the
end of the short story
um I think like the vampire lets Richard
go but none of the stuff that happens in
the movie like all the real [ __ ] up
[ __ ] that happens at the end none of
that happens at the end of the story so
the movie went way darker like and way
more cynical which I which I liked I I
liked that very much the premise of the
movies that there's a damn
vampire
flying around from airport to airport
in this pretty cool looking and kind of
sinister black
propeller plane little private airplane
it's got a it's got a push puller push
prop and a puller prop on it I don't
know what kind it is and an h-tail
they say what kind it is they said it
was I forgot what kind it was you could
buy it
it was just civilian aircraft
and it was painted like matte black
semi-matte black with red stripes yeah
and he'd fly in on that and then he'd
take over
go to the Tower and [ __ ] Mesmerize
people and turn them into his thralls
so they wouldn't call the FFA on them
because the FFA was looking for him
because he wherever he landed people
died so he knew about that airplane that
aircraft
but he could get mind control and then
he'd blend in with the population and
start killing people
eating them and stuff
he didn't just put holes in him man he
put sometimes he tore their throats out
and did all kinds of when these
newspaper reporters are trying to
make a buck off of it and take
photographs and figure out where he's
going to strike next and tell stories
and that's where that's where the that's
the premise of the story I mean and the
thing is at first uh obviously they
don't think it's a real vampire they
just think it's like a guy that's a
serial killer that thinks that he's a
vampire they're like because he
registers under the name Dwight Renfield
they're like oh haha like very funny
like you know Renfield the character
from Dracula and Dwight being a
reference to Dwight Frye like the guy
the actor that played Renfield in the
1931 Bella Lugosi version of Dracula so
um you know and him wearing the cape and
everything like that so they just think
it's a serial killer like [ __ ] around
but then like as The Story Goes On
spoiler alert it's absolutely it's a
real vampire yeah uh so so yeah so and
then I kind of like I know that the
original short story didn't have uh the
other like the the girl
uh you know that that was the other
reporter like that he calls Jimmy if you
could still like Jimmy Olsen
um but I like that Edition because it
really like I said gave Richard
something to play off of and also
there's like a competition because the
editor of the inside view which is the
name of the Tabloid that they work for
it's called a Cessna Sky Master okay
yeah that's right I thought I had
written it down but I guess I did it
yeah
um but
he like pits them against one another
like to see
I don't know I guess because he just
thinks it's funny or he thinks it'll
make a good copy or something like that
but I really like
I just really like like the cynical way
that this ended you know what I mean and
I love love love like the the last
sequence like when they go to that um to
that airfield like at the end and all
the people in the airport are dead and
then like he runs into the vampire like
in the bathroom and then he comes out
and like the the vampire like gives him
some of his blood and then everything
goes like real creepy and like black and
white he takes you into his world yeah
and like all the all the people get up
like zombies and [ __ ] like that and I
was like that was such a great it was
like so so creepy like with all the fog
and everything like that he's got mind
control and stuff and you're not really
sure what he actually looks like when
you he can look like I had some Dracula
dude with the damn cape with the collar
on it walking and it looks like a damn
bat wing in the wind he can look like
that
or he can look he he can look like just
a horrible damn demon with a huge mouth
with that damn cape on you don't really
know what he looks like he's controlling
what he's controlling how you see him
it's an illusion I guess
yeah because really
um they don't show him and I think that
was like a good choice because I thought
it was like really creepy like you only
kind of see him from far away like with
the cape like flowing out behind him and
stuff yeah and then um you know you kind
of see him and he looks sort of normal
but then like at the very very end like
during that great uh air or airport
sequence where you know Richard is just
like let me see your face and that's the
first time that you get to see him and
then you see that great [ __ ] like all
he's all [ __ ] up with that big mouth
and that big [ __ ] tooth in there and
[ __ ] yeah and it was just like such a
great reveal but you don't know if
that's the way he really looks or not
he's contr he
he's got mind control he can he can cast
Illusions so you don't know if that's
what he really looks he probably I don't
know if he actually had a cape that Kate
looked sick as [ __ ]
I don't know if he actually had that or
he made you see that
for all you know he might have just been
[ __ ] a naked or ugly ass
corpse
you might not have even looked that
strong but it when he unveiled himself
that and in that time he
look like Dracula
like imagine if Dracula was that was the
devil or something just her big [ __ ]
like pumpkin head with [ __ ] huge
fangs just one Big Fang that came out a
bunch of other little ones that
but I think it was all a
a glamor you know what they would call
it
in in occult Circle culture and it's an
illusion that is being forced on you
that that's how you're being forced to
see it
because it was I was all over you know
then he becomes pretty boy all of a
sudden you know it's it no he didn't
look like any of that I don't think
maybe he just maybe he just showed um
Richard that because he wanted to like
make him regret that he had asked to see
his face he says I'm gonna take you to
hell yeah
so I think it it could appear any way it
won't it probably didn't look like any
of that it probably looked like a Down
Rotten corpse
because there was worms in the in the uh
in the ground yeah in the dirt yeah and
I don't think clothing could have
survived living in that dirt with all
that putrid [ __ ] so it was probably nude
just a [ __ ] skinny ass [ __ ] corpse
yeah strong
with mind control and if it forced any
blood into your mouth that was a wrap
you were now you were now in a world of
hell or you would you couldn't see
reality
well I mean spoiler alert Like Richard
didn't last too long after he saw that
though which like I said is not how the
original story ended I think like the
original story he got away but he was
just like maybe he learned something
along the way about being such a shitty
like tabloid reporter like because he
actually saw the thing and he saw it
like how [ __ ] up everything was but at
the end of the movie they made it like
well they made it like he killed all
those people yeah or they made it look
like he killed all those people like
with an ax so like the cop shot him and
then I thought I thought like the the
cherry on top of it was like the the
younger like Jimmy Olsen woman coming in
and being all [ __ ] cynical and just
taking a picture of him and then like
ruining his reputation posthumously by
saying yeah he was the killer all along
and putting him on the cover of the
[ __ ] I was like that was so great
that's one of the like most cynical
endings of a movie I've ever seen and I
was totally there for it I was totally
there for it he had some good abilities
man he had [ __ ] mental Dominion he
could dominate people
effortlessly he could get federal agents
not to report him and protect him he
could get old ladies to want to
sacrifice to fall in love with him and
give up their lives for him yeah that
old that old lady went got her hair done
and all kind of stuff she would look all
pretty dead during the time to heat
[ __ ] killer bite her drink all her
blood and [ __ ] he could do and he could
you know just mentally dominate people
well she was dead and she was just
laying there in the bed like she was all
happy and [ __ ] yeah yeah that's his job
his job was to go around [ __ ] eating
people sucking people's blood
through big holes in their neck yeah he
did it by any way pulling their heads
off and whatnot yeah making them want it
or making dudes protect him and then uh
he could make dudes see hell and he
could punish you too you know
you know what's interesting is that
um you know Stephen King actually really
really liked this adaptation
and because they thought it was going to
do much better than it did which it
didn't sadly they were actually Stephen
King and um the writer the screenwriter
of this they had actually planned to do
a sequel
which I think was supposed to be called
fear of flying and it was gonna go like
into like a little bit of the origin
story of Dwight and uh kind of like
follow the other like the younger
reporter
and that would have actually been cool
but you know because this movie only
made like in its theatrical release even
though it was limited I think it made
like a hundred thousand dollars or
something like that you you could you
could remaster this Blu-ray Edition
re-release it and um I think it'll do
okay
you know because there's a lot of
Stephen King fans
yeah and honestly this is one of the
better yeah it's one of the better ones
adaptations like I said it's probably
it's probably not like a tier but it's a
lot better than I'll put it in B B minus
two yeah that's what I'm saying I'm
saying it's like in the B tier yeah in
the B area yeah
and it's it's entertaining yeah and I
got a good it's got some good it's got
some good ideas in it it's just that
when you see the the free YouTube
version you're looking at television
aspect ratio and and low resolution that
makes it look cheap
it didn't look that way in a theatrical
release guarantee in a higher resolution
it probably looked pretty good because
from what I could see
the Practical effects were good well
like I said that's knb they're like top
of the line yeah
and the acting was good with the the
acting was good it achieved the tone
that they were looking for
which it wasn't the same tone as say
like Salem's lot more like the tone from
um the stand television series or you
know like that
it kind of like it kind of leans almost
toward black comedy yeah I want to say
like it had some of the because like I
said they were trying to make uh kind of
a point about tabloid reporters being
like vampires too like you know or being
ghouls in a way yeah so they were trying
to draw that parallel but I just yeah I
don't want to go too far in that
direction saying it's like oh it's like
a black comedy it's not but it has like
aspects of that like it has kind of like
it's supposed to be a fun horror movie
that it has an edge to it
that is a vampire movie with elements of
slasher elements of you know a serial
killer type movie uh
it's it's just a good it's just a good
entertaining fluid it has a little bit
of a Noir vibe to it yeah like because
it's kind of like a investigation like a
detective yeah because that's pretty
much I mean you know that the the guy's
a vampire like pretty much the whole
time but you're kind of following
Richard and to a lesser extent like the
the younger reporter while they're like
on the trail and they're like
investigating like trying to figure out
where he went and like what his deal is
and [ __ ] like that so it's it has like a
detective story aspect to it too which I
thought was really interesting and like
I said it's kind of like it's a little
bit of an original take I feel like on
the vampire Mythos even though it's also
like kind of classic at the same time
yeah
I'd put it there in terms of like appeal
and appeal and over you know overall
enjoyability I'd probably put it there
with like fire starter the old fire
starter that level uh the Tone's very
different but in terms of just overall
enjoyment when you watch about like
Firestarter uh I think it's technically
better than fire starter yeah I was
gonna say I think I might live A little
bit a little bit probably like on par
with like dead zone in terms of
appeal although man Christopher Walken's
hard act to follow but still it's it's
just a good one what would you what
would you say that it was most like
see I want to say it came out in the 90s
yeah it was definitely one of the best
ones from the 90s well at least like in
the kind of lower budget tier just like
I said they did some like graveyard
shift and The Mangler which were like
not really that great
um this is definitely several steps up
from that yeah you know what I mean I
was I was trying to put it more with
like some of the classics that I like
yeah it's a modern
tone it's a different tone but in terms
of just like overall appeal and
watchability I I think it was as as good
as
the fire starter and dead zone you know
they're it's a different movie very much
so yeah because I feel like those two
were more like serious whereas this one
is kind of like like I said it's not
funny necessarily but it has like black
humor to it yeah it it's man and it's
much gorrier and Danny Rowling said sort
of like Needful Things but with a
Vampire Kinda Yeah similar I think I
like this a little bit better than
Needful Things yeah I do like Needful
Things but I think this was I like it
better than Silver Bullet actually and
it might be kind of more closer to snow
it's darker than several it is way
darker than Silver Bullet Silver Bullet
is like is fun it's a lot of fun this
one like I said I the thing that I liked
the most about this one what other than
like just Miguel Ferrer like his whole
thing he carries the movie he really
does I just really really liked how
mean-spirited this was because you don't
really see a lot of movies like that so
I thought it was like really balls this
is the biggest role I've seen this dude
dude this is his movie basically he runs
that [ __ ] and it does a good job man
he's really good in this movie
yeah I mean he he definitely definitely
like [ __ ] like you said he just
carries it yeah it carries us over he's
easily like the reason to watch and he's
he is just such a dick and it's just
like it's delightful he's starring in
this movie and normally he does not star
in a movie that actor normally yeah this
is really kind of like the lead role and
he didn't unfortunately he didn't see
him in a lot of lead roles which is kind
of sad because he's because he kicked
ass but yeah he did good on it but yeah
this is really one you're rooting for
this guy he's a dick and he didn't make
it he didn't make it no he doesn't make
it like I said in the original story he
did but uh here not so much yeah uh but
yeah I I really really liked it so I
really appreciate you guys like uh
recommending it because yes I mean I'm
sure we would have got around to it
eventually because I like to see all
this stuff to get around to everything
eventually
people pointing Us in the right
direction and we'll go look you know we
got regular listeners that point [ __ ]
out we go okay we take their advice and
yeah you guys come through a lot of
times and I remember this movie Very
vaguely in the late 90s very vaguely I
remember that vampire the head yeah I
remembered that
but I don't I don't I don't know where I
saw it
well one thing Danny Rowling was saying
this is one of the like the cover of it
like the VHS cover was like really um I
like really iconic like you see it
Blockbuster all the time but I'm gonna
say like I looked when I was doing the
um the card for this and I saw like the
you know the cover of the of the VHS and
I was like I think it might have been
better if you hadn't revealed the
monster yeah on the cover because that
that was what was so great in the build
up of the movie is like you didn't
really see the Monster until like the
very end like you just saw him from far
away and he sort of looked normal you
saw kind of that that real distinctive
looking Cape like the where the top came
up and it was like a little bit like
curved like it was bat wings or
something so I mean there were some
shots of it was like really creepy where
he's like coming through the fog like at
the airport and everything and I thought
that was really good that was like
really well done the way they built it
up and then they didn't show like the
[ __ ] big monster face like until the
end and I thought that was like a really
good moment like that was a really good
reveal so when you put the monster like
slap the monster face like right on the
poster right on the VHS you're kind of
ruining it a little bit like I get why
they do it because you do want you know
the cover to be impactful because you'd
be like oh yeah [ __ ] I want to see that
movie but then on the other hand it kind
of ruins the experience of watching the
movie too so it's kind of like I don't
know it badly needs a re-release it does
well it needs any release yeah it needs
a Blu-ray release
with a better cover on it it may and you
know what I mean to sell that advertise
that [ __ ] and it was some of these damn
Stephen King heavy fan fan
circles you know online
you'd sell some of this I think you know
[ __ ] I bought Dagon
I bought the Blu-ray release of Dagon
[ __ ] love it
um yeah I would do I would do like like
that kind of treatment
and the thing about it is that Dagon I
feel like that might even be lesser
known than this movie yeah probably yeah
because every single person I've asked
well I mean not you guys but like every
single person that I've asked even
people that like horror yeah I'm like
hey have you ever seen Dagon they don't
know dagon's a great movie and I love
Dagon great movie but that's and yeah
but I mean and Stephen King is like kind
of bigger yeah you know because there's
more adaptations of his stuff than there
are of like HP Lovecraft stuff which you
know I I know why that is because it's
harder to adapt HP Lovecraft stuff but
yeah this is definitely one that uh kind
of needs more love I feel like it was
it's really kind of a shame that it's
not like streaming anywhere like in HD
so you know hopefully like like I said
Arrow or blue underground or one of
those companies that kind of rescue
these types of movies from obscurity I
think this would be a good one for them
to do I don't know like how the rights
are working out and everything like that
but sometimes these movies get hung up
on things like rights and you'll never
see them that's what I'm saying that's
kind of a shame